يقع متحف القصر في قلب
بكين ويتوسع في هونغ
كونغ بمبنى مصمم لإيواء
المئات من كنوزها التي لا تقدر بثمن.
الذكرى السنوية الخامسة والعشرون
لتسليم المدينة من الريف البريطاني
إلى الصين
مهمة جدًا لمتحفنا حتى يتمكن من
سرد القصة التي تعرفها من أين
تأتي الحضارة الصينية وكيف
ترتبط الحضارة الصينية بالحضارات الأخرى
لأننا لسنا وحدنا على
حق ، لذا أعتقد  هذا مهم
بشكل خاص في الوقت الذي يكون فيه العالم
مستقطبًا للغاية ومنقسمًا
أكثر من 900 قطعة أثرية معارة من
متحف قصر بكين معروضة عبر
صالات عرض متعددة في هذا المعرض ، حيث
تسلط الأضواء على تاريخ الخزف الصيني
مع التركيز على
الخزف الإمبراطوري من مينغ  وسلالات كينغ
، يحتوي متحف القصر على 1.8 مليون
قطعة من أصل 8000 فقط
تم تصنيفها على أنها  كائنات من الدرجة الأولى
من 8000
قدموا لنا
166 5
وهي صفقة كبيرة
يجب أن تراها لأنه
فقط بعينك يمكنك حقًا
تقدير الطبيعة الرائعة للفن
الصيني الرئيس الصيني شي جين بينغ وقد
روج لأمجاد ماضي الصين
كجزء من رؤيته لتحقيق
الحلم الصيني في عام 2017 ، زارت هونغ
كونغ للاحتفال بالذكرى العشرين
للتسليم وأشرفت على حفل التوقيع هذا
بين بكين وهونغ كونغ
لتطوير المتحف في الوقت الذي
قال فيه إنه يأمل أن يعزز
الثقافة الصينية التقليدية  في الوقت الذي يتم فيه
تحقيق ضغط الرئيس من أجل القوة الناعمة الثقافية
في المدينة
، تم تقليص حرية التعبير بفضل
قانون الأمن القومي الذي تم تمريره في عام 2020 ،
ولم تعد مشاهد الاحتجاجات الجماهيرية أكثر من
الأعمال الفنية المشحونة سياسياً مثل
عمود العار النصب التذكاري لساحة تيانانمن.
تمت إزالة البؤرة الاستيطانية في هونغ كونغ
ستكون ثالث متحف للقصر
في العالم ، كما توجد العديد
من كنوز المدينة المحظورة الأخرى في
يتم عرضه في متحف القصر في تايوان
بعد نقل بعض الآثار الأكثر قيمة في الصين
إلى تايبيه من خلال تراجع
القوات الوطنية في الأربعينيات من القرن الماضي ،
لدينا هؤلاء الخبراء من بكين
والصين بالإضافة إلى تايوان يعملون
معنا في متحفنا لذلك يمكنني فقط
أن أتخيل ذلك  سيستمر هذا الحوار ،
آمل أن تعلم
أنه في يوم من الأيام يمكن أن يكون هناك تعاون فعلي
بين المتاحف
الثلاثة التي تضم ثلاثة متاحف تضم كنوزًا وطنية لا تقدر بثمن في الصين ،
لكن اثنين فقط يحظيان
بمباركة بكين بما في ذلك هنا حيث
يتم الشعور بتأثير العاصمة بالفعل.
kong
[موسيقى]